in der welt der unternehmensberater ist
zeit fast noch wichtiger als geld das
sehen wir einem fall einer jungen frau
namens lola fast gar nicht raus sie
verstand es ganz gut
er warte eine verspätung so läuft das
thema karriere zu machen sie geht auf
jeden fall scheint optimistisch
unterwegs werden daher maßgeblich in die
entscheidungsprozesse im vorstand bei
den banken eingebunden ist und er ließ
es sehr zuversichtlich dass werden ihre
chefin oder ihre vorgesetzte elisa
erhält auch große stücke auf sie
mehr eigentlich als beruflicher natur
die beiden haben auch ein
liebesverhältnis
[Musik]
mit einem wort muster formen und sie ist
auch komplett gesiegt das zu tun dann
drehte aber etwas ein was ihr leben
durcheinander bringt und das ist im kern
die geschichte der regen steigen der
boden unter den füßen über regen stein
hören sie nicht ihre schwester ist jetzt
da die schwester von lola begeht einen
selbstversuch wagen würde sofort gespült
die vergiftung haben ein christ sich hat
hat sie auch gesehen
je länger der film dauert desto
interessanter arbeitet marie kreutzer
das sehr besondere verhältnis dieser
beiden schwestern heraus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und da sage ich auch natürlich zu einem
gewissen grad eine individuelle person
ist eigentlich in erster linie so etwas
wie eine eine funktion die maschine
könnte man fast sagen sie versucht auf
jeden fall suchen so perfekt wie möglich
zu funktionieren und so wenig wie
möglich eben das persönliche zuzulassen
das persönliche kommt dann eben
gestaltet hat das rezitieren
schwester was willst du eigentlich fand
hier überhaupt nicht ich bin für dich
voran trägt ist eben eines eine person
die uns auch fragen stellt rätsel andere
reizvolle könnte man sagen aufgibt als
lola pinken 14 stunden gleich ans bett
gefesselt ohne wasser da in diese
richtung geht nun eben auch der boden
unter den füßen der einerseits
gesellschaftskritisch ist diese kalte
rationalität der unternehmensberatung
dem stellt sich hier etwas entgegen was
nicht einfach gefühl ist sondern eben
ein übermaß könnte man beinahe als sagen
an seele und in dieser spannung
funktioniert der film auch ganz
interessant
nur wer zu kreditkarten hass und fliegt
bis sie nicht mehr wert es ist kein
großes meisterwerk es ist ein film der
vielleicht ein bisschen thesen haft
wirkt aber der in diesen beiden
hauptdarstellerinnen vor allem eine
konstellation findet jedenfalls
dienstagnacht auf meine sehen für die
kohle
wo bist du tötete